françois a été élu par des cardinaux qui
voulaient du changement dans cette
église écorché par les scandales mais au
delà des réformes de françois c'est le
charisme de ce pape qui a séduit
tellement de gens et beaucoup
d'américains du côté de la maison
blanche de barack obama on est très
heureux de voir arriver arriva françois
barack obama a toujours clairement dit
il avait une admiration personnelle pour
ce pape là il du côté républicain
l'image et l'image et plus et plus
mélanger correspondant la maison blanche
jérôme cartillier connaît les
politiciens qui se passerait bien de ce
pape qui n'hésite pas à dénoncer les
excès du capitalisme
un très bon exemple c'est toute la
question de l'environnement
maintenant il ya beaucoup de
républicains un certain nombre de
républicains qui donc très peu apprécié
c'est tellement qu'on puisse dire les
propos du pape sur le climat et
notamment cette encyclique sur le climat
en substance il trouve qui s'est mêlé de
ce qu'ils ne regardaient pas en juin
dernier le pape publie un long texte où
il est question de changement climatique
c'est un appel au combat mais le pack va
le découvrir il ya aussi aux états unis
tout un courant de climato sceptiques et
un des plus redoutables
c'est marine ibères pour mary bale il y
a une bonne dose d'hypocrisie dans les
propos du pape l'environnement
l'avortement où les divorcés remariés
ce qui caractérise ce pacs et son
ouverture d'esprit qui provoque aussi de
vives réactions parfois au sein même de
l'église et locatives
c'est un personnage gay qui suis-je pour
juger ces demandes et le pas françois
cau de nos sexualités
il ya des gens dans l'église qui ont
toujours bien du mal à suivre françois
depuis deux ans maintenant c'est la
confusion qui règne nous dit john mrema
stone co-fondateur de voice of de famery
un groupe très attaché aux traditions
catholiques
pour lui le pape devrait plutôt dire aux
personnes homosexuelles que c'est mal ce
qu'elles font mais ce qui inquiète
particulièrement john nb weston c'est
tout ce débat autour des catholique
divorcé qui se sont remariés
c'est inacceptable dans la tradition
catholique et pourtant voici que
françois semble rouvrir la porte avec un
demi million d'autres catholiques weston
a signé une pétition pour supplier le
pape françois de ne pas ouvrir cette
porte
et parmi les signataires il y à au moins
sept cardinaux et des dizaines d'évêques
un affront public
du jamais vu
malgré l'immense popularité de françois
ce qu'on voit apparaître dans les
coulisses du vatican sur le terrain
politique
c'est une résistance farouche aux idées
de françois c'est à se demander si
françois n'est pas en train de jouer son
pontificat ici alain crevier washington